yeah welcome to this video playing
flotilla why don't you go 93 flow Zilla
from France and gum maybe I can't play
this London system for once I'm not a
regular London system player but it's a
it's a useful opening once in a while
for having a very solid position i don't
think i will played it in a tournament
game but sometimes it's a it's a good
choice in bin blitz if you want to want
an relatively easy to understand enter
easy to handle game so Queen 85 what is
the smooth doing and y'all 94 can play
maybe 94
yeah how to how to play the snow should
I just yeah maybe yep come on grab the
bishop am slaughter not bad and the only
compensation is is so by a slightly
weekend structure but okay it's two
bishops wow so you want to give me the
bishops without any compensation yet
okay so what now besides I can also play
a very direct North can't win before
just preventing his castles it's not bad
let's do that and see how he cancels now
a text b7 also
move like b6 is strategically terrible
the combination of b6 and Bishop f5
ourselves some catastrophe
hmm yeah but what does he actually
playing now yeah he probably recognized
that this is a a child will move to play
but he didn't find out a way to avoid it
the question is what now just look see
one or something or is there something
better you probably play a five but okay
we can do that a5 queen bee three it
still keeps lots of pressure on the
queenside if it plays a move like night
h5 try to get the bishop I can just take
and play Knight e5 this wins outright
threatening g4 and c6 but night at
shriver you need to get his King on in
the center yeah probably the only move
now even Queen d6 is not bad keeping
this strategy alive or from preventing
his castles now that this is simply good
let's go inside a service really like
Swiss cheese now
they can just develop or take on d5 if
this is always an an idea maybe you
should play a form but then come before
again 9 a-6 I can probably even take em
they form a math right at the moment is
just he takes d5 and it opens up the
Queen side with a point c1
hmm okay so take now probably night
takes I can just take the agency 6 or
take on be a play 95 it takes takes on
be at x e6 yeah should I just do that
yeah it's from a development point of
view it you don't want to but it's
probably the way to go knight c6 I mean
look c6 of course yeah probably should
do that that's a pole after all yeah
92
I don't know maybe I should have played
95 instead of Roxy six this some this
isn't dumb so super clear Jack what
what's the big truck here don't don't
get it oh now cam he's got some
temporary activity you can probably hear
ya you five but i have no def 3-yard
it's no problem can take on d4 with the
night
yeah this looks okay the pieces are
unsafe squares you always want to have
those safe squares where you can anchor
the pieces Alexi four yeah I only wanted
to make sure to have it all nicely
protected okay you cannot go to the
third because it was hanging wood I
thought the bishop can go to f12 to pick
up the poem and I can take be three
maybe kasturi turn you know it's covered
just cover that check check d 8 yeah two
extra piece snow check check check check
check mate yeah yeah he got he got some
play I mean probably Rock Texas six was
too early this is always a problem you
have not always but it sometimes happens
you have a strategically almost winning
position I mean even if the computer is
not so positive about that is this is
strategically almost winning for white
because it's full of holes I mean you
probably will win material but the
question is when went to question and
maybe this was the wrong timing this
year I don't know this looks like a bit
bit of compensation for black yeah maybe
we should be three SS simpler I don't
know
I also thought maybe 95 the thing is and
you do you have a developed piece and
take it take this awful night you can
also just play here and just keep all
your pluses to bishops a week poem
another week pawn those pieces I in a
potential fork and so on and it's um
it's very difficult sometimes to put
judge if this is the right timing to to
win the material I thought maybe this
one again and do them yeah it's also
probably better for whites but how much
this listen fact is it's a question
about something like this you have
problems getting your stuff out and now
maybe I should have should have just
done in this position just play this
simply asking black one what are you
playing now it's not easy me cannot do
that does this is this just really upon
he's got no nope no compensation oops
this is a very nice on the queenside
yeah thanks for watching